actually where i thought you were going
with your
little theory before when we were
talking about
why the traveling and the yeah yeah yeah
i thought that you were going to say
that
well perhaps they're not going home
perhaps they're not leaving earth i
thought you were going there but do you
believe that they have some space
sorry some base on earth maybe under the
water maybe on the other side of the
moon or something i think there's been
there's been a lot of suspicion that you
know a lot of talk that there could be
underwater bases
you know 75 percent of the earth's
surface is water
and we really have very little access to
it
so if you are going to hide out
somewhere that's perfect
and then to be honest if you're if
you're aquatic in the first place
let's say that you come from an aquatic
environment
aquatic environments on planets are
going to be much better
to live in than atmospheric environments
atmospheres have a low heat capacity so
the temperature varies a lot
throughout the day even right you get
huge temperature variations
um and then going from planet to planet
you have huge temperature variations in
the atmosphere
you know go to mars and you're looking
at 100 degrees below zero fahrenheit you
go
to venus and you're looking at 800
degrees fahrenheit
it's dramatic and the air pressure is
dramatically different
you know from planet to planet so here
we have one atmosphere of air pressure
you go to mars it's one one hundredth
and you go to venus it's a hundred times
you know so you've got four
orders of magnitude of variation of air
pressure
and and um
and then of course air doesn't do much
for protecting you from cosmic rays
and meteorites right so there's all
sorts of problems with living
on a surface protected only by an
atmosphere
but if you live in an ocean you know
going to another planet with an ocean is
actually
a pretty good thing if you if you know
it's a water ocean
then a water ocean on another planet is
going to be between the temperatures of
you know 32 degrees fahrenheit and you
know 212 degrees fahrenheit
so so the temperatures aren't going to
change dramatically from
ocean to ocean going from one planet to
another
and you can and because water's
not compressible the the pressures
aren't going to change that dramatically
either
um the pressures are going to be a
function of gravity but
you know a very deep ocean on europa
either pressure you know the pressure
halfway down
maybe 30 miles down into europa's ocean
is
going to be similar to the pressure at
the bottom of our oceans only five miles
down
so so you can actually find a nice
place to hang out if that's your
pressure you're used to
you know the only different the main
differences are going to be
the chemicals dissolved in the ocean so
are there some chemicals that are
poisonous to
you in that ocean or biologics you know
if there's
you know bacteria and things like this
that could be problematic too
but otherwise going from one ocean to
another is almost
going to be going pro for the most part
you know for survival purposes will be
very similar